Speaker 1: I am going to. Deal with an
issue that many people emailed me about,
and I don't know if I'm going to take
a position that my audience will find
refreshing or if people are going to be mad at
me. Some people will be mad. Joe Biden was pretty
clearly falling asleep yesterday at the opening
speeches of the COP26 Climate Change Summit.
He was clearly not just resting his eyes.
I'm playing the video here for the audience.
His head was nodding forward. There's
really no doubt about it. OK, Joe Biden was
sleepy during yesterday's COP26 morning
speeches. I don't think the left really
gains anything from denying it and pretending
that reality is not what it is. Joe Biden was
tired and the speeches were pretty boring, and
he's only been in Europe for a couple of days.
It's, you know, five to seven hours ahead of
East Coast, depending on which country you're in
your body in the best case adjusts one hour a day.
So in the morning when this was going on for Joe
Biden's body clock, it was like three or four
in the morning. Now, could he have had coffee?
Sure. Maybe he did. Maybe he didn't. We don't
know. I think that if we start engaging on Joe
Biden wasn't really falling asleep, and it became
pretty clear at one point a staffer went over and
kind of started talking to him or saying something
to kind of wake him up and maybe offering coffee.
Joe Biden seems to kind of say no at one point.
It's not clear what the conversation was,
but it's pretty clear that this is what it
is if we just say it's not what's going on.
We look kind of stupid. For me, the argument
is OK. So he was tired, but is much better than
the guy that he was running against Donald
Trump. Like what exactly is the argument?
I think that we need to make these this issue
about substance rather than just denying reality.
If you start engaging and he wasn't really
falling asleep. It just doesn't. It just kind
of a dumb conversation. He was falling asleep. OK,
he was. He was clearly falling asleep. Address it.
Head on. OK. Biden was falling asleep. He didn't
say anything humiliating or embarrassing at this
climate change summit, which Trump wouldn't even
have been invited to because he said that climate
change was a hoax created by China in order
to hurt American manufacturing. Trump, the
country of the U.S., was out of these discussions
under Trump because of the things that Trump said
he believed about climate change. And I can't
think of any real issue on which I would rather
have Trump in charge than Joe Biden, including
acutely what we're talking about here when it
comes to the climate. So that's my position on
this, and some people might write in and say,
David, you really shouldn't admit that Joe Biden
was falling asleep. But that's what was going on,
and I don't think we really gain anything from
denying the reality. I would just again. And so
what? I'd rather have Biden sleepy while other
people are speaking than Trump there or have
the U.S. not be involved at all. So let me know
your thoughts on that. If I'm missing something,
let me know. You can find me on Twitter at
Packman. We're going to take a quick break and
be back right after this. Remember that the David
Pakman show is primarily funded through individual
memberships from viewers like you, listeners, like
you, I would invite you to sign up at join Packman
dot com. Really appreciate every single person
who does it. We do an extra show every day for our
members. Sign up at Join Packman dot com. Use the
coupon code Felony 21 for a big discount. It's
such a large discount it should be a
felony. It's not, though, and you can use
the coupon code felony 21 to sign up.